hey guys merry here with gamespot
presents the mix at e3 2015 I am here
with Matt you're from infinite wrap
games infinite app games yeah thank you
it's so nice for you to be here and
people might recognize you from
neverending nightmares which was your
old game but you are showing off a new
nightmarish alliteration game called
devastating dreams today yes devastated
dreams is sort of a spiritual sequel to
neverending nightmares it's an all new
setting all new characters and it
actually draws heavily on Filipino
folklore so this are our main character
angel lives in a very rural version
region of the Philippines where they
don't have electricity or running water
and she's pregnant but in Filipino
folklore there are these monsters called
Aswang and the Aswang often prey on the
unborn fetuses that's pretty dark it's
it's very dark but it's very interesting
because this is sort of what they
believe culturally and and even to this
day in a lot of rural regions people are
afraid of a swung and follow various
rituals to protect their families from
them that's pretty fascinating you're
basing it off of real focal our new see
you also have it looks like you are
restricting the view for the player
based on only the light that's coming
out of their flashlight so is that more
of like to help with the element of
surprise because I mean will things ever
come behind her or scare her if she
turns around yeah definitely we really
want to create this oppressive
atmosphere and we have a procedural
lighting system that actually layers
different elements onto the the screen
to create the darkness effect and it's
sort of like these different patterns
watercolor patterns yeah so it's
definitely a sort of an interesting
way to create the this feeling of the
walls closing in and you have only your
flashlight to to defend yourself why is
she out at all like if I was pregnant
and it was scary I would just stay at
home well in this particular scene she's
going to try and find a doctor because
she's having some pain okay and oh
unfortunately yeah she she gets caught
in the roots and and there there's a lot
of horrifying elements in in the jungle
yeah I think I see some moving stuff in
the darkness around there makes me a
little nervous okay so you have the
ability to run can she defend herself
she can struggle to fight off certain
attackers but she's not going to you
know get a rocket launcher and absolute
all the enemies we really want to create
a horror game and not you know an action
horror game so we're very interested in
exploring themes of vulnerability and
also you know the idea of sort of
protecting uh you know her she was
wondering fighting people when she's
pretty much about do she's right about
to pop it looks like yeah my wife is
pregnant right now and also is is
Filipino so it's a very personal game to
me but yes we've we found that it's very
difficult when you're pregnant to do a
lot of you barely pick things up on the
floor let alone fight monsters it just
seems like a little much for someone
who's in their third trimester to take
care of yeah so it's definitely
challenging to try and survive all these
horrible nightmares and the the inhuman
abominations that she's up against so it
looks like you will probably have to use
a lot of sound cues in order to create
the atmosphere you're looking for here
yeah the the audio is arguably the most
important part of a horror game at least
in my book and we're actually doing
something interesting
we're we're using what's called a
binaural audio which is a way of
creating 3d sounds and sort of emulating
the way that people hear them and I
think this is what like a lot of
companies like oculus are doing with
their VR sound and so we actually have
the software to do that so we recommend
you play the game with headphones and
with headphones you can really hear all
the little details like you're actually
there and it's pretty horrifying
experience right yeah you would always
expect any time you're playing a horror
game to play it with headphones with the
lights off and you know alone preferably
so no one hears you scream or freak out
like a little baby and so how far into
development are you with us so we're
about six or seven months into
development and we're looking at
releasing a maybe third quarter next
year mm-hmm there's still a lot more to
to kind of fix or create here there's
like different areas that you're going
to be exploring yeah there's going to be
a lot of different areas and all
inspired by regions in the Philippines
so one of the themes of the game is
exploring a any area of the Philippines
that was hit really hard by a super
typhoon and sort of the devastation left
in its wake and how that affected the
people well she's gonna be going through
some [ __ ] before this game ends but uh
well that's the first look we've have at
devastated dreams thank you so much for
showing thank you for having sweet
that's devastated dreams you can keep
following up with that and for
everything else game and III related be
sure to head to gamespot com
you